Hi, I'm
Ramona J. Smith, Toastmasters International
2018 World Champion of Public Speaking.
You may know the feeling of nervousness or even
anxiety that happens when you have to speak in
front of others without time to prepare.
Maybe for an unexpected question during a
job interview or maybe when a teacher called
on you in class when your hand wasn't raised.
In your professional life, you may have even
been asked to fill in for someone else during
a meeting. I know first-hand that being put on
the spot is an intimidating speaking challenge.
Yet I'm one of millions of people
who Toastmasters has helped gain the
confidence to communicate in all circumstances.
Impromptu speaking is a skill that everyone
can benefit from. It can help you in social
situations, such as weddings and birthdays,
or even at work or school. We'll start
by looking at the times you might have
an opportunity to speak, then we'll move on
to techniques to manage last-minute speeches.
Practice impromptu speaking.
Let's begin with the many opportunities
to practice speaking spontaneously.
Meetings at work or in the classroom,
whether they re virtual or in-person, can
help you test your impromptu speaking skills.
There are many other common everyday opportunities
to practice as well, such as speaking with a bank
teller, customer service representative, or even
someone in line with you at the grocery store.
You might be invited to attend a
wedding, retirement, or engagement party.
These events are perfect opportunities to
practice impromptu speaking from the heart.
Techniques
Now that we've pinpointed a few
potential places of practice,
let's take a closer look at the techniques
to help you manage your impromptu speaking.
The first approach is a simple formula
known as PREP, which stands for: Point,
Reason, Example, Point.
Start your speech by
making a clear point about a subject. For
example, Internet outages are annoying.
Next, explain why you are speaking on the
topic, then give a few examples to bring
life to your story, and, finally, end with a
concluding point that wraps up your speech.
Those might include things like,
I m speaking on this topic because
it happened today and that is why I am at the
market, waiting in this long line. After that,
you might add another anecdote[A8] and finally,
a conclusion about internet unreliability.
By following this flow, you'll be able
to clearly state your main point and help
keep your ideas on course.
PREP is an excellent fit
for more professional settings such as
business meetings and even interviews.
Another way to manage your speaking
time is by following the pros vs. cons,
or positive and negative method.
Set up an issue by addressing the
pros first, the cons second, and then neatly
wrap up your point with your recommendation.
Pros vs. cons also works well in a professional
setting and in many every-day settings as well.
Filling in for a speaker
If you find yourself filling in
for a speaker, quickly think about how you
would open and close your speech. You may
begin by sharing a few personal stories, and then
engaging the audience by acting as a moderator.
You can encourage questions and answers
to extend the speaking time if needed.
Now that you've considered how
to prepare for your speech,
it's time to concentrate on the final and most
important step: delivering your impromptu speech.
The only way to master impromptu speaking is
by jumping in and practicing in real-time.
If you struggle with being a perfectionist,
don't stress. Simply try to have fun. Most
people at the event will applaud your
courage and willingness to stand in.
Stay on topic
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW ONE OF THE
PITFALLS OF SPEAKING AT A MOMENT'S NOTICE,
AND THAT IS THE TENDENCY TO RAMBLE. THE BEST WAY
TO ALLEVIATE THIS PROBLEM IS TO DRAFT AN OUTLINE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN TO SPEAK. THIS MAY NOT ALWAYS BE
POSSIBLE, BUT IF YOU CAN TAKE A MOMENT TO WRITE
A FEW NOTES TO GUIDE YOU ALONG, INCORPORATE
THE TIPS AND TECHNIQUES WE'VE JUST COVERED,
YOU'LL BE AMAZED AT HOW QUICKLY YOU'LL HAVE
THE CONFIDENCE TO BE A GREAT IMPROMPTU SPEAKER.
Practice impromptu speaking
Call out text:[A3]
Find practice opportunities in every day life
Full screen text:[A4]
Techniques
Up to you if you'd like to put
PREP at the top, and then the line text below,
or if you want to remove PREP from the top and
instead have it be evident in the list. You could
leave this list on the screen throughout this
section and somehow highlight the relevant
pieces of the list as she discusses it.[A5]
Call out text:
PREP
Point
Reason
Example
Point
Pros versus Cons
Filling in for a speaker
Stay on topic